the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I think it brings together I think some
of the business rate of travel but also
in fact the last word of the text or
liberation my point of the week and the
future so so this is our presentation on
language resistance in the liberation
welcome to the last day of class
congratulations
so as a roadmap we're going to go
through first rethinking literacy the
dialogue the piece by ferry and Mikado
get up Macedo and then we're going to
look at the literacy in critical
pedagogy piece and then end with the MIT
hati hati initiatives okay so this is
just a little bit of a background on the
writers of the first two pieces both of
them are educators and critical pedagogy
and ones from Brazil and one is caper
day an American so in the first piece
fairy mentions the permit the main
premises of culture and I think that
these are really important to keep in
mind because this is a really
interesting and I think powerful way to
frame culture the first one is that
cultural cultural processes are
intimately connected with social
relations especially with class
relations and class formations with
sexual divisions with racial structuring
and social relations and with age
oppressions as a form of dependency got
it the second one culture involves power
and helps to produce asymmetries and the
abilities of individuals and social
groups to define and realize their needs
and third one culture is neither
autonomous nor an externally determined
field but obsess but a site of social
difficulties and struggles
those ideas are really important to keep
in mind because this paper also raises
this idea I know it is the social field
which is kind of the combination of all
of the beliefs myths aspirations hopes
of a book of a society of a culture and
so it's includes things such as why
racial hierarchies exist
- why sexual divisions exist in like
what roles gender gender people play in
a society and it's really important to
keep that in mind because if you're able
to keep that in mind then you're able to
think critically about that and through
the critical process of engaging whether
you're able to change the social field
and so I think that that's important
because even though this paper raises a
lot of really powerful ideas it's still
not perfect so one of the quotes of this
paper is literacies oral dimension is
important even if it takes place in the
culture like that of the United States
whose memory is predominantly in not
oral like that of Africa Africa somatic
and so something like that is also part
of the social field and would make it
into this paper because even though
ferry and Macedo are thinking critically
about this they are not engaging with a
full reality of cultural objectivity and
being subjects within that yeah the next
article Paulo fury
talks about the use of language as
resistance and he first starts talking
about how the current traditional
methods on literacy how they tend to
ignore the importance of language in a
person's education and he bases a lot of
his theories on his experiences and from
the second quote he says that the sad
reality is that while education and poor
yeess provides access to positions of
political and economic power for the
high echelon of African society it
screens out the majority of the masses
who failed to learn Portuguese well
enough to acquire the necessary literacy
skills for social economic and political
investment and you could definitely from
the way that he mentions this you could
definitely see a lot of like parallelism
between what's going on around the world
and currently like in the United States
and you could you could definitely see
that the the 1% usually have the most
control over things and that usually
tend to drive all policies for me but
the fact is is that when a person is
taught and during native language
detents you learn things better and
comprehend things faster and you go to
the next leg there's usually backlash
when it comes to different languages
taught in schools for example in the
u.s. people say that students should
learn how to speak standard American
English but when it comes to providing
these sort of opportunities to minority
group so I guess for instance letting
students of color there's usually some
regional tensions that develop that that
made minority students feel inferior for
example there was an article mentioned
like recently in like March of 2017 that
talked about a robotics team and I
received that recently had won the
challenge and the fact that after di1
students targets people in the crowd
started screaming at them and telling
them to go back to Mexico and so this
form of like demeaning commentary tends
to drive the dropout rate so of minority
groups and all this tends to contribute
to like the prison sorry though the
school to Prison Pipeline as you can see
in the infographic
give us a lot of percentages on that
talked about this sort of issue in the
bottom when he says that 60% of all
males enstein in federal prison they do
not have a high school diploma and this
sense to me gives the statistics on
students cook and all of this tense that
tends to stem from the fact that
minority students do not have the same
access to education as deeper society
and from personal experience I can
definitely relate to this I went to
school about like an hour and a half for
my house and I definitely did have a lot
of like good role models growing up but
there were definitely and students
around my neighborhood that get in found
that definitely didn't have the same
access to the same opportunities that I
did some of them did drop officer ring
others worried big gangs around my
neighborhood and you could definitely
these are definitely getting better but
things could definitely be improved from
any medicine and emancipatory literacy
approach which is what Paula Ferry
mentions yeah
so in a monetary literacy this involves
using the language of the people rather
than the need to teach students to
accept their experiences and their
culture and this moves from the world of
objectivity to the world of subjectivity
where individuals learn to accept
themselves for who they are rather than
feel like they're a victim of society
and pollen fury does mention that
achieving emancipatory illiteracy is
hard but it's not impossible and now and
so learning was talked about a few
examples of how this is being used today
so considering specifically in the case
of Haiti which Michelle works a lot on
but that mighty Haiti initiative
virtually all of the schooling in both K
through 12 education and then
higher education is done in French and
not in Creole but the problem is that
most people only speak Creole fluently
so like 95 percent or so and very few
people speak French fluently at all so
when you go through school and
everything is in a language that you
don't understand how are you supposed to
be able to actually get any of the
education get any of the social
engagement especially if children are
punished for speaking Creole in school
and they like can't interact with each
other it can't ask questions can't
gather any of the information that's
coming at them so it's based on this
false belief and really outdated belief
about the hierarchy of languages about
which languages are created or are
younger or anything like that and that
Creole isn't developed enough to be able
to to be used for technical language for
STEM education to have anything
translated into Creole and part of that
is saying that like Creole isn't
widespread enough even though Creole has
almost 10 million speakers finnish has
only about 5.5 million speakers and yet
in finland all of the education is done
in finnish and people have studies have
found that in finland kids are much
better much better equipped to be able
to learn a second language and to go
into higher education and gather gather
all of these like technical studies
because all of their education is done
in finnish and over i AP i was doing
misty GTL in the Catalunya region in
Spain and there
Catalan also has a little under ten
million speakers but in Catalunya all of
the education is in Catalan which made
it difficult for me as like a Spanish
speaker like not even fluent but trying
to speak Spanish speaker to be able to
teach the students but they had such a
better experience with all of their
textbooks in Catalan all of their
computer software so I was trying to
teach them Inkscape and [ __ ] but
everything was in Catalan and I just
couldn't understand like even how to
open a window um so they taught me a lot
about this
they all of them speak Catalan and
Spanish and English and then they can
like learn German or French on the side
as well so all of them because their
initial education K through 12 and then
higher education if they want it to be
is in Catalan then they can learn all of
these other things just as well as we do
like in English with it which is mostly
our one and kind of only language in the
United States yeah so that was my
experience and what a school that is
like a really good model in Haiti is the
lkm school I didn't know how to
pronounce it in Creole so South cam it's
a catered tent in school in a rural part
on an island of Haiti and their
education is starting to be in this
model of all Creole education trying to
teach all of these subjects all of the
technical terms in Creole and the
students are learning much better than
the rest of the students in Haiti whose
schooling is in French and who only 10%
graduate from high school
so the linguistic apartheid part of this
is that when you teach somebody in a
language they don't understand you
prevent them from being able to move
into different socio-economic classes to
attain the education and the success
that they should be able to and this all
leads to a mighty Haiti initiative that
Michele started here between MIT and all
the hatred education systems so a couple
of their main points are to teach
educators in Haiti that teaching and
creole is perfectly fine that it is
actually better for the students that it
gives them more opportunities and that
stem and technical subjects can be
taught in Creole so a lot of the worries
or concerns are that like Creole doesn't
have words for these languages we didn't
have words for a computer either up
until when they were created a lot of
other languages borrow words from other
languages so I learned Japanese and in
Japanese there's this lovely thing
called katakana where you just grab
where's your mother languages so if you
don't know how to pronounce it you kind
of like make it sound like it and
oftentimes it is what has been
so for example bread is paan from German
and all of these other languages have
words borrowed from other languages and
that's what globalization does so the
same thing should be able to happen with
Creole and stem learning and the really
good results of this or that they
affirmed students cultures and
backgrounds and their own upbringing and
how the society actually works as
opposed to a colonial oppressive society
and it equalizes students being able to
have more social mobility and to attain
what they want and what they should be
able to so to kind of tie this back to
what we can do to stay woke with regards
to literacy I think it's important to
remember that language is a mediating
force of knowledge but it is also
knowledge itself and so one approach is
for groups to kind of come together and
create a language that describes their
experience amongst themselves and then
to share that language and to share that
experience in their own in their own
language and I think that that is one
way that we can start breaking away from
the kind of putting Standard English on
a pedestal and can also kind of validate
other discourses and other ways of being
and other just languages that kind of
already exists in the US and across the
world
questions okay how have our
understandings of literacy evolved in
response to the internet unprecedented
global integration and increased
pressure to preserve human rights for
example what does it mean that schools
repress the development of subjectivity
but due largely ensure literacy
how can modern notions of literacy
evolved to address phenomena such as the
prolific proliferation of fake news so
if we're moving past literacy as just
the idea of being able to read and we
are entering this new kind of this new
way of being that's not really pushed by
the internet and the influence of
technology on the way we live
literacy is coming to being a more
critical approach to life in the sense
that fake news is a thing you know and
it's actually quite hard to distinguish
what news is real and what news is fake
and the ability to do that having that
critical lens is maybe the next
evolution of literacy so any ideas that
I guess is the question but something
that I think is kind of hilarious about
like integration the Internet is that I
think it simultaneously making us more
literate and less literate so like or
like crushing me to be more literate so
pressuring you to be more literate like
now there's a bunch of sources that you
can read and like now you can be more
educated it's all open to the public you
have a computer and then there's also
like the pressure to speak English
properly based off either you know like
this one viral videos old grandma's
screaming at this
because she was paying in Spanish or
something like that so like it puts
pressure on you to speak English
correctly and then meanwhile because of
like things like Facebook and like any
social media people like don't speak
correctly like typing like you know
abbreviations and stuff that's
acceptable I'm taxed but like I mean
while we're saying like you should speak
English properly so it's kind of a weird
dichotomy I'm interested in the age
implications of what you just said kind
of aligning kind of a critique towards
the use of different varieties of
English with older generations and the
use of non-standard varieties of English
with young captivation and interested in
that mm-hmm yeah I think I mean I guess
like so like there's a grandma that I
know that's on Facebook and like she
like make sure it's to like type
everything out including punctuation
like her facebook posts are longer and
like they're more like here's a card I
think today where is like my facebook a
I'm just sharing things but B if I write
anything it's probably so I think it
does depend on like your age but also
like going back to the original point of
like you know that grandma's screaming
at the Hispanic woman like an IHOP like
it's not just like an older woman
screaming because you know she's more
illiterate like there's also like kids
who like to think like oh you have to
speak English up here so like they're
you still if that weirdness between like
how like older people like act on
Facebook and stuff like that I still
think like the point of you know
pressuring people is regardless of age
I think because I'm going to be talked
about language versus dialects in this
class I would kind of risk saying that
we're kind of creating a new language
because of the internet with like all
the abbreviations and things and there's
the way push for speed and everything
like that so I think the reason that old
generations don't use it as much is
because it I used to it and then looking
at different like frame of reference and
they didn't have it like learned this
new dialect that we're starting to use
so I think that it's a good thing in a
sense but a lot of people who want that
standard American English are going to
be pushing us to go back to that as
opposed to using the Internet the goings
parts like are tainted taste in literacy
because of the internet like I didn't
know what the onion was satire at first
but I said at the end it existed and I
thought I realized that it was satire I
think step new ones like that is
something that you miss especially with
the internet because you can't really
express sarcasm very clearly over just
plain text I think that's something that
we're
but I think that he said we talked about
the onion I think that shows and shows
like that show that
I want to bounce up with you Ritchie
said like with like it's not a bad thing
that we're tending my language I
creatively it's kind of another
dimension do you think like there are
certain rules like the way we type and
length is they're like oh you illiterate
like like punctuating my question is so
knowing now that people grow up in a
type of leadership whether it's a
traditional emancipatory what are the
pros and cons of your type of literacy
and explain why we should move either
towards or away from it from an
emancipatory leaders
I mean if it's helping people learn I
don't see a downfall especially because
it's kind of broadening their worldview
I a couple of presentations ago there
one of the students who are playing
jeopardy with AE and that was kind of
like broadening their worldviews like
even if you went to the school it didn't
speak any you are learning about a new
language that you weren't familiar with
and so they were able to do this through
the inspiratory literacy what the
so kind of just play devil's advocate a
little bit I think I guess one of the
dangers of emancipatory
literacy might be kind of this non
standardization like with initiatives
like Common Core things like that we
kind of have an educational system that
setup so that everybody's kind of put on
the same level to some extent like
everybody has that same kind of baseline
education but like with emancipatory
literacy i think you're gonna find my
educational programs are geared towards
a specific like cultural norms and
things that nature related to whatever
population and targets so i wonder if
that could potentially produce a system
in which certain students even though
they're receiving an education nice
appeard towards them it's objectively
not that same quality of students who
are would seem like more of a
traditional approach I want to push back
on that just a little bit because I
think that the standardized approach to
education is the approach that's been
taken with the you know teach for test
approach and it's failed it's been
failing for a while now and I think that
a lot of people in education policy and
even just teachers are recognizing that
now and I think that education
emancipatory literacy gives us an
interesting lens to think about how to
educate people so that they can learn
and I think maybe another place we can
start kind of investing energy is
thinking of ways in society that we can
value those different ways of knowing
and being and learning so that it's not
just uh you went to college so you
deserve to be paid a lot of money kind
of thing and it's uh oh you can you know
build the table from scratch how do you
get paid to do that
I think MIT is way far the tradition MIT
is the alt-right of traditional
literature I just think that there are I
think that the the immense pressure that
falls on students just on students
physical bodies is definitely a symptom
of a larger problem and for me the fact
that that symptom is not enough of an
impedance to change is heartbreaking
because I think that I did I didn't I
didn't come to college expecting it to
be the four best four years of my life
but I didn't come here also expecting to
this suffering I think that there's
definitely got to be a way where I can
can bloom can reach my best potential
and I love learning I love like I loved
school you know and the fact that I yeah
I have just kept running up against the
institution I think as a creative person
has made me kind of step back and think
again about events but sorry literacy
and how I can do that
after given what you just say I want you
to issue it to be mit president what
would you change what how would you make
it better more individually keeping in
mind that yesterday because I just reach
in terms of a chemist how would you do
that how would you how would you advise
the ministration I think the very first
thing I would do is have people who are
more interested in research and not be
professors so the ones who are
interested in research should be doing
research full-time and the people who
are interested in teaching should teach
because I think that that gives like a
that gives people more impetus to just
like connect with their students and
actually get to know them and I think in
that kind of environment you would
foster like a safer healthier
environment for learning whereas if you
have a professor who is more interested
in like winning the Nobel Prize like
what are you like what do you do coming
up against that I also would have MIT
think very very hard about where the
funding is coming from what it's going
to and how that kind of fits in a global
system where MIT as an institution fits
in the global system as kind of
not only an institution that does propel
you to a higher class but kind of does
that at the expense of a lot of other
people and systems across the globe even
if it's not directly in the area so I
think that being more critical and
intentional about our values and also
maybe adding soul to the end of that the
end of that motto
the last question is from your personal
experiences or what you've seen or read
about how do you think we can improve
students experiences and confidence
through intentional language use in
schools like what mottos do you think
are working or would work good common so
bouncing out that and seems like we get
to like everything where's the next
platitudinous is inculcated in this like
standard curriculum goes into society
and I'm a protector is the static
critical back on VM students so I'm
curious about if anyone has thoughts
about how you could make knowledge about
is one of them a hurdle to see the like
instituting or like entirely the same
person just strictly chief about how the
story of America's history is in with
the idea of the new jet size slavery and
the for lack of ever mean that is
manifest destiny how do you make people
aware of that on a level that they can
see those things playing out to a and
work to entire that curriculum
especially they're coming from
background we're like racism talk about
another
I think or if they just like haven't
okay sir manipulating flows out to
Newark where you learned to interrogate
your own beliefs and I feel like that's
hard to find and I came to this class of
later keep part of that for me and I
don't know if that was people that I got
started out or just like it happened to
stumble upon a place where I learned
interrogating families but this isn't
the main put themselves but I don't
really have an answer for how we get
choked with a value in interrogating
roebling's and I have much more like how
do we have conversations with people who
don't want to have this conversation and
I think like the only way for them to
figure out for them to interrogate
there's also like most those people
won't
so like finding ways to tarik like to
make the matteri themselves I think is
it any like a common problem like
throughout history and like unfortunate
I don't know if I personally have a
group like solution for that but I think
like more opportunities like this I mean
obviously like you mentioned this before
like the people who are taking this
class we're not really diversified I
thought right like we all saw this class
out mostly so I don't know how you can
get someone who doesn't wanna Terry
sounds like it is situation like this so
maybe like mandating something like this
where you have to go to like a black
history class or a Native American
history class or like whatever might
force people to start
the history will speak for itself I
think that history is like if you know
they pulled a full history unlike the
United States for example it's pretty
it's pretty terrible and I think that
you do need to know the whole history
and also need to get the alternative
sides and have those be like integrated
into the curriculum I also was
interested in I'm thinking about like
entry points into these conversations in
like ways that like art and humor can
function as entry points in the
conversations I've been having this
conversation with a friend of mine of
how like humor for example gives us a
way to kind of express some of these
things that are more taboo and kind of
laughed them off and kind of like
integrate them as opposed to everyone
shutting them and people feeling bobbled
so I interested about like humor and art
specifically as entry points into these
conversations sorry this will do that
right so if it's right right should be
what we imagined I think every class
like they're good please critical math
class chemistry class or being attention
to those issues inside a room for that
even even if you take it simple
photographic one can even think about
what kind of choice is going to making a
camera and actually I have photographic
with me that I feel most cameras will
not be able to think because of bad
people so even my photographic effect
that makes a picture with his regular
Canon of the white person becomes much
better in Windex of a bad person why
because the lenses are designed with
with the normative gaze of the white
subject all right so we had to tweak his
camera
Kenickie take good pictures of practice
so even there even in physics there's a
way to interrogate the the curriculum
why committed this event successful so
in a way it could be both you could both
have the military within the current
code more discipline and then going back
to the last point in imagine also in
history in biology value could include
text like I mentioned earlier is too
common on the mismeasure of men which
was into lots of ethical issues about
biology how we make hands were measures
to show that women are intelligent power
factor for many years when you were
coming in here to dress you take a
picture naked and they would look at
your picture inside what kind of student
you will become missing a physical trait
like because you're handsome one of the
most prominent of microscope and
phenology you know which is the measure
so there is clinic plenty of room to
integrate those kind of the treaties
with in Greek life okay
you